yeah i moved out here when i
i went to orange coast college in costa
mesa which is just
right up the street from me now uh i
took an emt class there
that's where i got oh yeah yeah yeah go
pirates yeah
oh yeah and uh it's
it's like a community college it's you
know it was it was so fun
and uh i i basically moved to orange
county because my parents i thought
i would just get [ __ ] gang raped if i
moved right to la they were like
they're like you're too cute
to just move right down like yeah you
couldn't argue with it
because that booty was popping at 18.
and
uh baseball butt yeah i had that
baseball but donk
and yeah so they were just like
well i actually saw the movie orange
county this is the reason i moved to
orange county i saw the movie orange
county it came out when i was like 17
years old or something with colin hanks
and um jack black and
the whole premise of the [ __ ] movie
is colin hanks is like
he he wants to get out of here and he
doesn't want to go to the community
college
down the street uh where it's just
nothing but
stoners and and dumb hot chicks
and all uh every all everybody does
every day is just smoke weed and go to
the beach and
he needs to get out of there and i'm
like i need to get there
i'm like that's where i want to go to
school
yeah and so my parents were like okay
it's not you're not living right in
hollywood you can go there and then i
went there and then two years later
i got i had like zero transferable
credits i think i had six
i took two years of school with six
transferable credits
and uh all i took was like improv
classes and creative writing and you
know screenwriting
and uh so i couldn't go to an actual
four-year college
after the two years and so i was like
i'm just gonna
give comedy a try and my parents at that
time were like all right
whatever yeah
yeah dude